da gestern Abend hinter meinem PC ein
Kabel angefangen hat zu brennen
fragt einfach nicht nehmen wir das
heutige Video auf jeden Fall in einer
Küche auf
und noch nie gekocht wurde ich weiß
nicht ob ich der einzige bin aber ich
finde in vielen Fällen die Kommentare
unter einem tiktok deutlich witziger als
das tiktok selbst zum Beispiel hier da
ist ein Fußballer der ein über krankes
Tor schießt und die Kommentare
[Musik]
Roberto Kalorien
Miroslav extra Soße
Lionel Fressi
Leroy Schlagsahne
sadio Menü
Christian
[Gelächter]
ibrahimo Chips
Sperling Harland
Diego Maradona Franz Beckenbauer
Mark André schwer Stegen
Menü neu
es tut mir so leid bei diesem nächsten
tiktok zeigt jemand seinen Finger
pausiert das Video und der Finger sieht
einfach brutal krumm aus er stellt
Finger statt Bein
er kann von seinem Bett Licht
Ausschachten wie kommt man auf so einen
Scheiß er zeigt dir den ganzen Weg
das nächste tiktok ist von Gerolsteiner
also der wassermarke und die haben
selber ein tiktok hochgeladen indem sie
meinen ey warum werden wir eigentlich
immer gehatet Gerolsteiner schmeckt als
hätte man sein damit gewaschen
so was wenn Gerolsteiner eine Person
wäre wäre
lieber verdursten als Geräusche
einer schmeckt halt die letzte Schluck
aus einer Flasche Wasser die seit einer
Woche
also ich meine ja es ist true
Gerolsteiner schmeckt extrem beschissen
aber sieht halt einfach daran weil es
die besten Werte hat trotz Elektrolyte
und so angeht also Calcium Magnesium und
so und je mehr ein Wasser an diesem
Werten hat also je besser eigentlich ein
Wasser für den Körper ist desto salziger
schmeckt deswegen wusste nicht das
Wasser unterschiedlich schmeckt nach
Gerolsteiner wusste ich wie schlecht das
Wasser schmeckt Gerolsteiner ist das
Oettinger unter was auch bodenlos
genauso wie dieses 5,0 das schmeckt
Wasser aus einer besser als
alles Gerolsteiner größte bag
schmeckt halt bisschen wie das Wasser
unten in den klobürstenhalter drin
weißt du das Toilettenwasser mit Sprudel
langsam ist auch ein bisschen krank ist
selber Mobbing ne bei diesem nächsten
tiktok vergleicht eine Person ihr Race
Walking mit 13 und
[Musik]
ich beim 800 Meter Lauf wenn meine
Lehrerin sagt ich soll laufen ja true
ich auf dem Weg zum Klo wenn Gott los
kacken muss damals als laufend
[Musik]
oder laufen weil das sieht immer affig
aus aber man will auch ein bisschen
schneller gehen und der Person zeigt
danke das aufhält im Schwimmbad wenn man
nicht rennen darf oh mein Gott stimmt
Schwimmbad gesetzt wenn man Rennen
fliegt man oder wenn man das gleiche
Tempo geht
kann man auch aus Maul fliegen statt
2023 jede Woche dreimal ins Training zu
gehen werde stattdessen zu einer Person
die dreimal die Woche ins Training geht
das ist einfach genau das gleiche und in
den Kommentaren stehen Sachen wie ich
gehe die Woche Jim mal ins Park
ich gehe drei Wochen am Tag ins Gym
ich komme drei
Wochen
ich gedacht
drei Jahren an einem Tag ins Gym
ich gehe dreimal am
Tag die Woche
ich Jimmy drei Wochen die Tage hey mein
Humor ist so wer nervt jetzt bei diesem
tiktok möchte ein Typ sich an einen
Mädel daran machen und ihre Freundin
greift ein und beschützt ihre Freundin
vor dem Typen und schickt ihn halt weg
und die Kommentare sind wieder so
gottlos Inferno Tower Level 14 schreibt
ich bin da Leute
Hagrid always
ich sehe gerade in der Suche oben steht
fridge protections
aber ich verstehe den generellen Sinn
dahinter auch nicht lass doch deine Frau
sich anquatsch der Typ wollte doch
nichts Böses der die doch jetzt nicht
belästigt
auch dieses neue Lied von Shirin David
was jetzt raus wartet seitdem ich ich
denke einfach nur so darf ich als Mann
jetzt überhaupt noch irgendwie mit
meiner Mutter machen
vor die Tür gehen oder in diesem tiktok
hier zeigt ein Typ seine Dance Skills zu
einem Bruno Mars Song und die Kommentare
hier ne
50%
, 55
mach mal halblang
der Macht nur halbe Sachen
jeder fängt mal klein an
roblox
Bro drive a hot wheel
letzten TV in the background it's the
tablet ey
also er selber nimmt das auch mit Humor
so das finde ich dann immer ganz schön
wenn Leute sich sowas nicht irgendwie
weiß nicht fertig machen lassen sondern
das mit Humor nehmen aber tiktok
Kommentare können echt bodenlos sein
allerdings machen wir weiter mit diesem
nächsten tiktok und zwar schreibt er
dahin Bro why does the temperature
change every day is literally the exect
same Sun also quasi auf Deutsch
übersetzt warum haben wir jeden Tag eine
andere Temperatur wenn es doch über die
gleiche Sonne ist die uns anscheinend
und in den Kommentaren steht einfach
drei Bein
Albert kein Stein Albert Bio Wein
Albert Ziegelstein Albert nein nein nein
und Harvard cold ich muss
bei diesem tiktok hier filmt jemand
seine
spielte Teppich und macht halt eine
Transition also ein Übergang und der ist
halt extrem schlecht also wirklich sehr
bodenlos ich habe wenig erwartet und
wurde enttäuscht bleibt nicht dabei Haut
Gänse lass dir von Hatern was sagen der
Wille zählt nicht schwach angefangen und
stark nachgelassen Fehler machen dich
schwächer hinten Talent immer aufgeben
hör nicht auf die Supporter lass dich
bitte unterkriegen zeig den Hatern dass
sie richtig liegen ich glaube wenn man
dünnes Fell hat Kommentare echt
eine kranke mobbinggrundlage kommen
allerdings auch schon zum letzten tiktok
für heute und zwar diesem hier er filmt
sich und schreibt dazu ein weiterer Tag
an dem Frauen für Tampons und Binden
Geld bezahlen müssen ich bin 1,86 kein
Plan warum das dahinter noch geschrieben
hat weil es absolut nichts mit der
Aussage davor zu tun hat aber Leute
haben es genauso gemacht in den
Kommentaren Bro bin 140 x 2 Meter kallax
Regal endlich spricht es jemand an
Speisequark im Aldi schon 1,49 € pro 250
Gramm mein Therapeut braucht
mittlerweile auch einen Therapeuten
verstehe sowas einfach nicht ich besitze
viel Immobilien in München wichtig dass
jemand das anspricht bin 3,99 m ja mies
unfair Schuhgröße 41 ich finde das
unmöglich habe 50 Millionen Power bei
Rise of Kingdom der Bruder spricht
Fakten 4,30 mit armg sprachlos ich bin
drei bei dich so eine inakzeptabel
Situation den 4 x 4 Meter und damit
meine lieben Freunde würde ich